by popular demand and I do mean very
very very popular demand Old Yeller
this is the one I probably got the most
criticism over skipping everyone
proclaims it a Disney classic and the
reason I didn't review it before is
because quite honestly I had never seen
it before the reason well everybody
ruined the ending for me I won't give it
away here but let's just say if you know
the ending you kind of get the idea what
kind of story it is and even though I
knew it was probably good I kind of
avoided it saying to myself I might
rather see a film I don't know the
ending to but Disney cember rightfully
so has forced me to finally look at this
film that's been loved by so many and
yeah it is really really really good
honestly it's among one of Disney's best
the reason being that a story like this
can so easily be done wrong it can so
easily be made to corny it can so easily
get wrapped up in sappy music or overly
sympathetic speeches and especially
being Disney you would think that's what
was gonna happen in this film but it
doesn't it has a very nice consistent
tone the story centers around a family
whose father played by Fez Parker has to
go away for three months on a cattle
trail he declares his son played by Jeff
York to be the may have a house to run
things and make sure the farm goes
smoothly and all that good stuff but he
gets off to one heck of a bad star when
a stray dog makes all sorts of trouble
scaring away the animals eating up a
bunch of the food just being an
all-around pain but his younger brother
says he really wants a dog and the
mother seems to kind of agree a friendly
animal even if he is a troublemaker
would work out well seeing how the
little brother now has very few friends
to hang with seeing how his older
brother is now taking care of everything
but the older brother vows never to like
the dog while over time the dog does
prove his worthiness and of course they
form a strong friendship from this point
on it's nothing but the experiences and
adventures that him and his dog share
yeah that's right no straightforward
villain no money scheme know any of that
dumb as crap that we feel we have to put
in these other family films it's just
the experience of a boy and his dog and
you
what if it's done right that's all you
need and this film clearly does it right
a lot of that centers on two things one
is our main actor he does so well
playing this kid who is constantly
getting crapped on but still tries his
best to pull things through you can see
the frustration you can see the
aggravation you can see him getting so
angry over all this but at the same time
when things go well he does legitimately
enjoy that to the whole film centers
around when he's supposed to be tough
and when he's supposed to be sympathetic
when is it time to fire the gun and when
is the time to put the gun down in this
environment those are not easy choices
and this actor does a wonderful job
showing his struggle through it all and
speaking of environment that's the other
thing that is done so well in this film
the pacing tone and atmosphere plays a
big part in why this movie is such a
success it establishes that is a very
tough dog-eat-dog world but at the same
time there can still be very joyous and
happy moments and it doesn't shy away
from either of them when tough really
depressing stuff happens it acknowledges
it but when really happy upbeat stuff
happens it acknowledges it too it never
spends too much time with either one it
equals out so well to keep kids
entertained but at the same time teach
them about the sometimes very difficult
world without them being afraid of it
when you get to the end message which is
so in-your-face it can't possibly be
escaped you really do find that the film
all the way from the beginning to the
end
truly supported it it's a coming-of-age
story that showed at leaf for the time
it was made the hardships of life and
the joys of life again in a g-rated
Disney film so the graphic stuff isn't
too graphic but once in a while that
kind of makes it even more uncomfortable
when they're stitching up Old Yeller is
that just so much more uneasy when you
don't see it being done they really know
how to get the point across even if they
can't show everything plus I didn't know
Mike Fink was in this movie holy smokes
I totally what seen this earlier if I
knew that now there is one problem I had
with the film even though it might be a
side note to many is how well are these
animals being treated I'm not talking
about in the story I mean like the
actual making of the film
I don't usually think about that stuff
too much but I'm looking at a lot of
this footage and I was kind of
uncomfortable with some of it
I mean the two dogs fighting okay that's
just for a housing no biggie but a dog
going up against a bear could they
always make sure that nothing dangerous
was gonna happen there but the way this
kid just tosses this frog in the snake
in fact what a flying fuck did you give
a kid a snake I know that kind of snake
is not likely to bite but it's still
giving a kid a fucking snake I mean
maybe they were treated okay and it's
just really really good effects but I
don't know you got a dog chasing a
rabbit that's one thing and then you got
them running under a mule that's another
thing and then you got the mule running
off after them it just isn't some really
dangerous shit I don't know I could be
reading too deep into it and it's years
in the past but it made me feel a little
uneasy but on the whole the film is like
everybody says a really friggin good
film
it doesn't need to rely on villains or
complicated plots it's just a little
slice of life written with characters
that you care about in situations that
you want to see them get through and all
the heavy moments in the happy moment
never seem out of place they seem to
just melt into each other so naturally
it's emotional it's effective it's a
damn good movie I know most of you have
seen it but even if you haven't and you
know what's gonna happen in the end I
can assure you as someone who is in the
same situation it's still definitely
worth checking out
Oh